sin resolución a inicios de este año
hubiese sido comprar sólo lo necesario
probablemente no lo hubiera podido
cumplir pero producto esta pandemia
definitivamente estoy haciendo cambios
estoy incorporando cambios que ya son
parte de mi nueva normalidad y es que
sin querer sin darnos cuenta hacemos
estos cambios más que todo condicionado
por factores externos del planeta y
déjenme explicarles mejor con este
ejemplo de mi infancia no que olvidaré
una ida a la playa con mi familia en el
verano del 86 cuando mi mamá agarra y me
embadurna la cara y los hombros con esta
crema blanca y pegajosa y me dice que me
cuide mucho del sol que me mantenga en
la sombra porque el sol es supremamente
peligroso y me podía matar
entonces imagínense el shock
que significó para mí esa escena esos
recuerdos
ya con el tiempo luego aprendí que se
trataba de el agujero en la capa de
ozono que ya sea refrigerante sintéticos
que la están destruyendo y alterando que
hay muchas implicaciones en nuestra
salud y también que hay países que se
pusieron de acuerdo con los tratados
internacionales y la capa de ozono desde
esa época hasta el día de hoy apoyo
recuperada pero sin embargo desde ese
campamento hasta el día de hoy en mi
conciencia se quedó el hecho de usar
protector solar todos los días de mi
vida inclusive si es que me quedo en
casa y nosotros
pero bueno desde hace varias décadas la
comunidad científica viene demostrando
con hechos que nuestras actividades
humanas están causando daños
irreparables sobre el planeta y ahora
con esta pandemia la naturaleza nos está
demostrando que es una verdad que es una
realidad
y bueno mi primer encuentro con la data
científica
afectando el ambiente fue universidad
especialmente en dos cursos que llevé
para robarme el ingeniero pesquero y uno
de ellos se trata de conservación de los
recursos pesqueros donde aprendí que los
recursos marinos son limitados y que
tenemos que anualmente establecer cuotas
de pesca de manera justa tanto para
pescadores como para la industria
transformadora en que teníamos que
establecer periodos de veda o periodo
gen o pesca para que el recurso pueda
recuperarse y también para que la
industria sea sostenible
otro curso que también marcó mucho mi
formación en temas ambientales fue el de
contaminación pesquera donde aprendí que
los procesos ineficientes traen consigo
pérdidas de recursos de agua de energía
y esto conlleva a generar gastos para la
empresa y también generar impactos
ambientales para el ambiente para el
planeta entonces al graduarme tenía
clarísimo clarísimo que si iba a
trabajar en la industria de díaz debía
de ser para proteger los recursos para
proteger los mares el océano y también
buscando ese balance entre lo social
entre lo económico y entre lo ambiental
porque una industria saludable debe
estar diseñada para prosperar no
necesariamente para buscar ese
crecimiento el conducto
sin embargo desde los años sesentas el
modelo de desarrollo para solucionar
todo problema económico de un país de
una industria de una de hasta de una
familia no está enfocada en que se debe
de tener un mayor crecimiento que se
ventas que se en ganancias crecen bienes
y servicios en recaudación de impuestos
en tener más en tener muchas cosas al
final porque el concepto de crecimiento
económico estuvo diseñado sin pensar que
hay recursos limitados o que los
recursos naturales son limitados en este
planeta y con el paso de las décadas
hasta nosotros como consumidores nos
vimos como atrapados o como seducidos
con este concepto de prosperidad que
para ser prósperos debemos siempre tener
más prósperos y felices debemos siempre
tener más pero si seguimos pensando de
esa manera pues definitivamente no nos
ahora voy a luchar
buscando el crecimiento económico hemos
puesto tanta presión en este
extraordinario planeta que ya ninguno de
sus sistemas puede recuperarse todos sus
sistemas están alterados de alguna forma
y esto está causando el calentamiento
global está causando la degradación de
los bosques está causando la pérdida de
la biodiversidad la destrucción de la
capa de ozono la acidificación de los
océanos y muchos otros problemas que han
excedido los límites planetarios de más
de 11 mil años de vida que tenemos
nosotros como especie humana habitando
este planeta
y bueno con todo esto el siglo 21 se
convierte en un gran reto para la
humanidad podemos acaso satisfacer las
necesidades de todas las personas con
los recursos naturales disponibles si
seguimos caminando viviendo ejecutando
un modelo económico creado diseñado el
siglo pasado
creo que no verdad
por décadas hemos vivido bajo este
modelo económico lineal de tomar
transformar usar y votar y creo que
a veces
hay mucho en mucha evidencia hay mucha
información que nos está diciendo lo
contrario
y todo esto puede sonar como que hay
mucha teoría pero hace sentido cuando
comparamos los símbolos milenarios de
prosperidad de civilizaciones antiguos
que tenían este equilibrio dinámico pero
a la vez circular como por ejemplo
el tag harán de las mayorías
el yin y el yang de los taoístas
el nudo del infinito o budista que me
encanta mucho
y el doble espiral
pues bien entonces no hace más sentido
que el nuevo modelo económico del siglo
21 sea también dinámico y circular con
los símbolos que hemos visto
nosotros como primeros habitantes de
este siglo 21 sin ser conscientes de
esta realidad que por todos lados nos
demuestra que necesita un cambio
no tenemos acaso en la responsabilidad y
la oportunidad de hacerlo diferente
crear economías desacopladas de los
recursos naturales o de nuevos recursos
naturales que sabemos que son limitados
poder generar economías con energías
renovables como la electricidad el
transporte en el caso de ciudades y
también para la industria en pensar en
agricultura regenerativa que pueda
conservar o que menoscaben la
biodiversidad amenazada donde usemos
plataformas digitales tecnología 3-d
también toda la parte de inteligencia
artificial para diversificar
diversificar aplicaciones industriales
entonces
con todo esto si creen que la idea de
crecer bajo el límites ya los está
limitando piensen que es momento o esa
oportunidad de ser ingeniosos y de
innovar porque todas las grandes
personas son las personas más ingeniosas
del mundo convierten exactamente esos
límites en su fuente de creatividad por
ejemplo moza con su piano de 5 octavas o
jimi hendrix con su guitarra de 6
cuerdas o serena williams que transformó
la forma de jugar tenis al día de hoy
son los límites los que desatan nuestro
propio potencial y son los límites del
planeta los que deben de despertar
de despertamos como humanidad para
cambiar y para prosperar
entonces yo te invito a ti no es momento
para que tú transformes tus límites en
beneficio del planeta
gracias